when barriers are going up and when
there is a risk that new diseases such
as corona virus will trigger a panic and
a desire for market segregation that go
beyond what is medically rational to the
point of doing real and unnecessary
economic damage then at that moment
humanity needs some government somewhere
that is willing at least to make the
case powerfully for freedom of exchange
we will engage with Japan and other
trans-pacific agreement countries with
old friends and partners Australia New
Zealand Canada on whom we deliberately
turned our backs in the early 1970s we
will get going with our friends in
America and I share the optimism of
President Trump and I say to all the
naive and juvenile anti Americans in
this country if there are any there seem
to be some I say grow up and get a grip
the u.s. already buys 1/5 of everything
we export and it goes without saying to
all those conspiracy theorists who may
still be in existence all those
believers in the Bermuda Triangle or who
think that Elvis is shortly to be found
on Mars it goes without saying that the
NHS is not on the table and we will not
accept any diminution in food hygiene or
animal welfare standards but I must say
to the America bashes in this country if
there are any in doing free trade deals
we will be governed by science and not
by mumbo-jumbo and on the great
environmental issue of our time perhaps
the greatest issue facing humanity
Britain was the first major economy
in the world Letta lend the EU to place
upon our own shoulders a legal
obligation to be carbon neutral by 2050
that will put huge strains on our system
we know that set it will require thought
and effort and change